was a Tom Curren Tom of course covers
the Patriots for NBC Sports Boston joins
us now
oh yeah that's timely to come up with
that question hadn't thought about that
one in a while huh
no well what question
I was talking to Francie oh the Brady or
Belichick oh yeah well no I mean
honestly I was stunned to see you come
back 65 percent Belichick 35 percent
Brady stunned I mean one guy is the
architect the other one's the Builder
he's hammer in the nails out there you
disagree with this you would you would
say Brady more valuable more responsible
than Belichick absolutely okay
absolutely from 2007 on I really think
it's been Brady especially 2010 through
2019 it's really Brady has given them
such a huge margin for error and you saw
it last year and they start a season
with such a complement of wide receiver
and skill position players that they
have to go and trade for a guy who
hadn't done anything since 2013 to give
them help and he did so for 11 games in
Josh Gordon so he allows them I mean
Aaron Rodgers would be in a fetal
position crying if he was asked to do
the same things
the Brady's annually they yelled at the
same way okay what what is Brady asked
to do that Aaron Rodgers wouldn't be
able to handle Lippett when I give you
cordarrelle Patterson and I know he
actually had time Montgomery in this
backfield for a period of time who we
are the number 80 but when I'll give you
cordarrelle Patterson as your running
back or I'll give you a season in which
we lose Aaron Hernandez and we're going
to start with Kem Brel Thompkins Aaron
Dobson and Josh Boise of wide receiver
and unproven Julian Edelman as your slot
or you know we're just going to nickel
and dime it on offense to a large extent
we're going to spend our money on
defense or maybe about this we're going
to sit down our our 98 percent of the
plays cornerback in the Super Bowl and
see how you can do on offense to keep us
afloat maybe you can throw four five
five oh that's not enough we lost yeah
too bad yeah I still go back it's not
like Belichick did that for a degree of
difficulty for Brady here I don't know
what the real reason why you know you
sat down Malcolm Butler but I don't know
if we'll ever get that full story but I
think it's a great point by me then of
course it is
as always Tom Tommy Curran the Patriots
insider joining us Julian Edelman out
for three weeks big deal little deal I
think it's a little deal in the grand
scheme but it actually refers back to
something we were just discussing for
Brady you go into camp and you'd like to
be hitting the ground running and with
the Patriots complement of skill
position players around him they don't
have a left tackle really right now
might be Isaiah Wynn and he could pan
out but he's never played because it was
her last year rookie Nikhil Harry and
then you have guys like Dontrelle in
minute Maurice Harris
there's no tight end since Gronk retired
and Watson's here but he'll miss the
first four games so it's instead of 700
level offense the Patriots are going to
be enjoying it's Brady on the rug with a
bunch of little kids playing frocks and
learning the alphabet and starting
they're against it going against a
defense that is going to be pretty good
and I can see Brady in camp when it's
hot and it's the ninth rep in a row
where they're about to get their asses
handed to him on a situational third and
12 a breeze like what are we doing why
do we do this every year but so that's
my take on that but grand scheme no it's
not going to make a huge impact that
Edelman isn't there but I still do think
they're going to be swimming upstream
offensively for a big portion of the the
first half of the year what did you
think of Edelman's documentary I liked
it I liked it and I wrote that book with
him two years ago which investigated it
was a memoir so it was basically in his
voice so it kind of went through all the
same things for 278 pages I'm like why
we did a documentary I just wrote this
thing but the documentary I thought was
very very very well done I went into it
saying you know I'm not going to like
this having just done the book but I
thought the creativity of it really
really made me shut up but did you need
to hear an explanation
- why he used performance-enhancing
drugs what he used what did it make him
feel like like it's a documentary and I
thought we were owed at least that if
you're gonna pull back the curtain pull
it back for a documentary and he didn't
that was I thought it was creative how
he got around it yeah and even when he
came on to talk about the documentary we
were given a heads up don't ask him
about you know the the steroid use but I
needed a little bit more there yeah it
does leave you but and that's just the
way honestly if someone has covered this
team throughout the Belichick regime and
regime is a good way of putting it you
come to accept that things are not going
to be spoken about
and unfortunately journalistically you
become conditioned to shrugging and
moving on so yeah I'm looking I'm like
how's he going to do this that's how he
did it and then I move on so it doesn't
probably grate on me as much as it ought
to because I'm conditioned to get over
it again I'm like I'd like to know you
know where it happened did it happen in
LA did it happen out here did it happen
in Honduras was it strictly to help his
recovery I mean I think that when Rodney
Harrison had his situation in 2000 and I
believe it was 2008 you know he
explained that it was about recovery as
he was coming back from an ACL was was
that what Julian did I think that would
benefit him so that people aren't saying
well there's been a lot of suspicion
about him throughout his career which is
something Chris Simpson last year so
more is less but we don't always
experience that here do you believe that
the Patriots were trying to move up to
take Baker Mayfield and oh you don't I
think that was a complete ruse they had
there was a that was a dog and pony show
okay
because I remember when that report came
out and I you know caught wind of it and
then you know they it it felt like you
know somebody was leaking something and
I didn't know whose camp it was coming
from and you know I think Mena Kimes in
her profile and Baker Mayfield and the
mothership on ESPN brought it up and I
didn't know
and I think I even asked you about this
after the fact was that true and I think
he said the same thing you're saying now
that no I've gotten more information on
that since you know when talking to
people and how was described to me it
was it was a dog and pony show huh
there's no attention tom jump jumping in
the water in Costa Rica with his
daughter is that the lead you know in
Boston asking Patriots questions with
Brady people flip out when you say
anything like that and and I do too look
you'd rather have an involved father I
think over you have four kids I know
that you know Satan and and Paulie
McLovin all probably have procreated at
some point the things that if you had
video of the dumb things I did with my
kids that I go whoa that was a close one
I don't want to share it on social media
but he kind of blissfully goes forward
and does it and takes the slings and
arrows and moves on I'm sure that Vivian
Brady will at some day say boy I love
doing things with my dad that what
seemed risky and crazy and he forced me
to to do things but if she had gone
bouncing down the front of the you know
rock face I mean that's what I said when
I looked at Oh grabbing the arm geez
wonder if she ended on him well I
haven't seen any news reports so I'm
sure she's fine
and will we ever have a run like this
with coach and quarterback that this is
the 20th camp with these two you know
I'm writing something right now about
Brady's contract because it's Tompa
Lucero Telus arrow noted yesterday
there's nothing on the horizon but there
are conversations which hadn't been
before it's not a Cold War necessarily
but it's not Cahuilla either but I think
that even this how can it be hard
this guy has given you tens of millions
of dollars back over the course of his
career in taking less he's made you
hundreds of billions of dollars and it's
still last year when it came up they
gave him a five billion dollar incentive
Laden thing of which he hit none
guys are not going to swallow hard like
Tom Brady has and say okay I'll sign it
I just want to win doesn't happen that
often so I don't think it will happen
ever again but do you think is he gonna
sign no it's gonna be difficult because
I'm like Andy Reid's not gonna stay for
Patrick mahomes entire career like if
you just look at these younger you know
Freddie kitchens isn't gonna be there
for Baker Mayfield's entire career and
who knows if they're gonna play 20 years
in the NFL and I think that'll be more
likely the guys will play the 20 years
just based upon Brady and Brees and
Phillip Rivers and every other rosters
and Vince Carter but I yeah
Roethlisberger but ia yeah I just think
that it's too much of a and ask for the
coach to be put in that position I mean
look at the AFC so they have to cycle
through every three years head coaches
in quarterbacks because they can knock
off the Patriots and that's what retards
the progress in the division less so
than the team's the Patriots hitting at
the right time it's those teams can't
make it to the playoffs so they throw up
their hands too early do you think Brady
cares about these lists where they it
feels like he gets denigrated whenever
there's a list out and like who would
you start your team myth or you had one
quarterback for your your one season who
would you have and you know Brady sort
of gets kicked to the curb a little bit
but I'm wondering if the great
competitor chip on his shoulder you know
that this bothers him still or it
motivates him I think it does and I
think that's why he covets rings and I
think that's why the 2017 swing and a
Miss and the Super Bowl really pisses
him off he should be at seven and I mean
I know people could say tuck rule and
this you know different plays but you
can also say Asante Samuel in 2007 or
Mario Manningham in 2011 or Wes Welker
and a guy who'd have frickin nine so I
think that he takes solace to being able
to say look I'm six and three in Super
Bowls and you know he can go
score over three of them I was I was I
did my part yeah I I'm just I would love
to know how he would talk just to his
buddies when he sees a list where it's
like you know Aaron Rodgers is the guy
you want or you know you want Patrick
mahomes or whatever it might be and then
you know here's Brady where you know it
feels like everybody's trying to shove
him out the door and it just you know
he's just building another bedroom to
come back in you know it has a massive
belief in his own ability to the point
where yeah I don't think he would
denigrate the other guys as much as he
would say what are we talking about it
would be great just to hear him say like
just have him look at the list in real
time where you say hey this was put out
by pro Football Focus or whatever you
know was putting out the list you know
they got you down there like what would
Brady say do you think privately if you
had it in that list and said you see
where Chris Simms has you're ranked we
got you behind Andy Dalton here for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]